During times like these,...
...it seems like the world will never be the same.
But there is a light beginning to shine again.
The spark began where it always begins,...
...at a restaurant downtown,...
...in a shop on Main Street,...
...a factory around the corner,...
...entrepreneurs like these are the most powerful force in the economy.
They drive change and they'll relentlessly push their businesses to innovate and connect.
As we look to the future, they'll be there ahead of us,...
...lights on, showing us the way forward.
This is just the beginning of the reinvention of business.
And while we're sure we don't know all the answers,...
...we do know one thing for certain,...
...we want to help.
Come see what the beginning looks like...
...at openforum.com